Elon Musk founder and CEO of Tesla's set
out to reinvent the car and the
California company has indeed shaken up
the industry as the big car makers
gradually follow suit with immobility
Tesla forges ahead it's already rolled
out three models the Tesla's Model X is
a cross between an SUV in advances
contest around a lipstick it has two
electric motors one on the front axle
and one on the rear
i'm--yeah the going doors make it much
easier to get into the car did I stay
thoughtless today mama no there are two
more seats behind the back seat the
front doors open by remote control the
exterior and the interior the Model X
make it seem almost like a space shuttle
it comes with five six or seven seats
our test car has six to get into the
third row the middle seats can be moved
forward electrically
[Music]
Tesla's models do without buttons inside
everything is controlled fairly
intuitively over a huge touchscreen at
five point zero four meters long the
Model X looks like a mixture between a
van and an SUV coupe a it's dimensions
are very different from conventional
SUVs but despite its 2.0 7 meter width
its form is elegant the trunk is rounded
not angular which actually comes in
handy for daily use and the North Ronnie
says just step on the brakes the door
closes automatically in the motor
switches on now all you have to do is
put the car in gear and you're on your
way
we're driving the 100 D variant of the
Model X its motors put out 386 kilowatts
and accelerate it to one hundred and
four point nine seconds Tesla says it
has a range of 565 kilometers before
recharging
[Music]
- Romi enthusiastically compares the
cars pick up to a rollercoaster
he's also impressed with the creep mode
when you take your foot off the
accelerator the car decelerates rapidly
on its own see being wearing the brakes
I'm believable for a 2.5 ton SUV he says
but Ronnie's WoW is quickly followed by
an uh-oh parking spaces are narrower in
Europe than in the United States so can
a California car's goal wings open
without incident as a priority
Ronnie is worried about the back door
will it open without any problem will I
get stuck will it scratch the
neighboring car he gathers up all this
courage and presses the button the door
opens supported by sensors if they see
that there isn't enough room they don't
let the door open further the Model X
passes the test but what about vertical
limitations for example in a parking
garage
it's impeccable marina parking garage to
see whether the rear door is open here
as well under such a low ceiling in one
Zita omits the doors operate with great
precision says Ronnie respectfully one
centimeter of clearance but the door
stopped and you can still get in very
comfortably 59 striking all the doors
open electrically but quite slowly this
car isn't one for quickly tossing a bag
into the backseat there are electric
charging stations that charge you as
well jokes Ronnie but Tesla also
operates superchargers that currently
recharge for free you can also recharge
the Tesla at home from a standard outlet
but with such a big battery that takes
quite a while the supercharger is a lot
faster it takes just 30 minutes to
provide enough energy for 270 kilometers
charging up is very simple sister Ani
just take the plug and press this button
50 1000 plus the battery's flat plug in
the cord and kill a little time Tesla
owners can use superchargers at no cost
for now but that will surely change
because Tesla has to pay for energy too
Tesla is currently working on solar roof
panels for private homes so that it can
offer renewable energy to its customers
Tesla's Model X is a family car a race
car and a smartphone on wheels all in
one says Ronnie but this is no
conventional car whether it's the
external design with the Goldwing doors
or the technology inside the Tesla is
persuasive and it's ranged between
charges is more than adequate not
everyone will consider it worth its
price 110,000 euros but that's another
question